um
i'm sorry what's that large sparkly
dazzling thing on your finger claire
crawley
that's the question yeah the season 16
bachelorette may have just dropped a
major hint about how her time on the hit
reality show
ends because she was just spotted
shopping in her hometown of sacramento
rocking a big and i mean
massive diamond on that finger
um i'm sorry say that again to be clear
this is a different rock than the one
claire addressed a few weeks back
the one that she said she wore on her
left wedding ring finger as a symbol of
commitment to herself
yeah this this doesn't appear to be that
was this love at first sight like i said
it was one of those intangible
goosebumps all over the body like just
what just happened while claire has
stayed tight-lipped about how her
season ends are you in a relationship
are you engaged
i'm very happy we do know claire hasn't
strayed from her night one front-runner
former nfl player
dale moss am i making you nervous kind
of
oh am i not making you nervous you
shouldn't
you should be laid like this on me huh
yeah and promos for thursday's special
episode of the bachelorette
seemed to indicate that her journey on
the show is about to come to an end
you've just blown up the bachelorette
this is hard and a possible future with
dale
could begin i'll apologize if i wasted
your time
i'll apologize if i hurt you when e.t
caught up with bachelor franchise host
chris harrison last week he reminded
fans that the whole goal of the season
was for claire
to find love i definitely
am not disappointed in claire i'm not
mad at claire none of this
is a bad thing if claire's falling for
somebody and that's where this goes
then great like the whole purpose of
this is to help claire find love
and if we help claire find love of great
if i do it in record time that should go
on my record that should be a good thing
um so that that there shouldn't be a
negative to this but chris did admit
that some of the other men
may have felt cheated by the experience
we thought
wow this is this is really coming to a
head quickly and
i think our first thought was well this
will continue on and
it'll ebb and flow like normal seasons
but when we realized
there was only ebb and no flow we
thought
we need to look at what we are going to
have to do
of course the solution to that problem
bringing on new bachelorette tasia adams
she was always a fan favorite she was
always a favorite of the producers
and so she was always on the top of our
list clearly we went with claire
and that was a great choice because
she's done a phenomenal
job at falling in love
but if things take a turn then we may
have to make
make a turn as well and make a change
watch it all unfold on a special episode
of the bachelorette thursday on
[Music]
abc